gang the middle class famous tour is
about to be in full effect come out and
see us it's a great way to introduce
some new people to the show so grab the
homies grab the ladies the birds the
bozos everybody and come see us yeah
guys we're going to be in hartford
albany syracuse atlanta tampa orlando
pittsburgh buffalo we ain't done yet
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago then over there to roseman and
that's just the first leg of the tour
gonna be coming so get the techies we'll
see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is r.u garbage it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that at
the earth to be classy yeah or they're
just a big old piece of trash i'm your
host nate's foley coming at you on a
glorious day down here at antoni's
basement yeah she is officially off
probation
good for her so we got that going we're
gonna break out a little champagne later
okay maybe do a little drinking and
driving have a little fun
back in the roundhouse my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the ceo of ru garbage he is an
international businessman he is not to
be trifled with they say he's the guy
that brought down merrill lynch but
we'll never know i'm more of an enron
man
give it up for kj hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true
[ __ ] cooking and obviously i'm
contractually obligated by law i think
it's a federal law now to mention
patreon.com ru garbage yes sir the
greatest website of all time you can
sign up you get bonus content episodes
ayg episodes of hard feelings live
streams the whole [ __ ] nine yards
check it the [ __ ] out check it the [ __ ]
out and having a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the man who
makes us all look good puts the lipstick
on the piggies give it up for tebow and
mcskruffins toby mcbuggins what's up
dudes what's up
bug freeze the way to be here we go
i was gonna say something about how
akash makes me feel talented and loved
and you make me feel like a beast
that's my goal buddy you're the best
you're the best
because i love you all right
foley what made you pick turquoise as a
beanie it's
not you yeah
i'm not gonna be i'm not gonna deal with
this on my own podcast that's ridiculous
dang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly special guest back with
us again today he's a part of the
goddamn family around here all right
co-host to flagrant too got a brand new
smash that came out last night it's
already cooking it's called bring back
up poo yeah you know them you love them
give it up for akashi
thank you thank you for attacking my
style thank you
turquoise not me it just doesn't seem on
tutty i think it pops uh dude he
wouldn't buy turquoise i feel like paper
take it from goodwill
but i don't think she would buy she also
drinks cooking wine i'm not doing that
i'm not taking my fashion tips from her
up there drinking marcella wine on the
rocks
on no rocks i think you're losing a
little weight a little bit we don't lose
a little weight we're not doing a
weigh-in we're not checking the weight
for at least a month or so that would be
pretty good right now though i just
reminded we have the scale under the
couch
not gonna happen
why it's redistributing i don't know
what that's all in his ankles
his shoes won't die
my trainer just squeezes me every day i
put you in a core set every day like a
wet towel
but he's been hitting the gym i'm very
proud of we've been hitting the gym i'm
not a trainer you look good thank you
man thank you thank you we're trying
we're trying here we're how's it going
three months into the therapy three
months oh therapy therapy we're about
three months in
five years the trainer we're two months
in so it's been good that's great
from you buddy you you encouraged me
well you put the [ __ ] screws to me is
what you did and you put it in their
mind to for me to get a trainer and now
i'm now it's [ __ ] hard as [ __ ]
in an entire future kippy give me some
his entire future is tethered to you
think about that fat guys are a dime a
dozen
there's a pizza place right around the
corner
i'll just have ian fighting start
bulking up and you'll be out too sweet
start putting creatine in his pellegrino
getting it all bulked up nah you and ian
got good chemistry too but y'all's
chemistry is [ __ ] phenomenal oh thank
you and it doesn't work if you keep
being fat he's i think wait i've painted
them i mean we do on uh on patreon i'm
in the tightest quarter i've ever been
we do fast i'm still pulling some moves
every person yeah he's got a couple
buddy every corner is attacking a couple
of cheeseburgers up my sleeve
uh but he has i'm very i'm very proud of
him to get the ball rolling in no that's
great to be where you are three days a
week at the gym i got a uh four days at
arby's
they're my off day
the gym is that new diner on 46th street
by the way um and yeah walking the rest
of the time the the diet is you know
something that we're slowly kind of you
know
modifying yeah you know what i mean it's
not about gold thank you yeah it's about
making decisions like my trainer was
saying if you get a cheeseburger don't
get the fries or if you get a
cheeseburger who is your [ __ ] trainer
that's the horse colonel sanders what
are you talking about
that's crazy if you get a cheeseburger
don't get the fries put down the bargain
effect [ __ ]
[Laughter]
take you to flavor town baby
emerald also works there bam
no just you know it's it's it's a
process it's a process yeah you know
there's some steps forward there's some
steps back but you know that's the way
it goes i mean
you're giving the [ __ ]
there is no trainer i've been lying the
whole time i'm in a rebuilding season
that's what we're doing
so you're talking like you just lost the
super bowl i got a couple of good
prospects in the g league right now
though
foley just read us his december 31st
instagram caption from when he didn't
lose weight
limited therapy a lot of steps forward a
lot of steps backward
i'm a working program yeah i look like a
human boomerang just like going back and
forth new me in 2023.
gang you got the smash yes sir let's
talk yeah man i put out my first special
i'm super excited about it i ran it you
guys saw it well i've seen it a good
amount of times uh but yeah i ran it uh
one of the days i filmed it was i had
you all featuring for me yes nice at
stress at the stress factory that's what
it's called right yeah stress factory so
i put it out it's called bring back a
poo
and i wanted to put it out pre-pandemic
and then obviously you couldn't do
stand-up for a year and i was thinking
after the pandemic was over i was like i
want to make sure i still felt this way
about things and i was so passionate
about it and i was so as i got my legs
back underneath me stand up wise i was
like this is it this is the special
let's put it out about a half hour-ish
and the idea is all kind of centered
around this this whole um privilege
conversation that we have where like we
say like white men have all the
privilege and to me it's like bruh if
you're in america
you probably got a lot of privilege yeah
i know yeah and look i'm gonna say one
time i know black people this doesn't
really apply to you all cause y'all been
systemically [ __ ] everybody else you
are lucky to be here my parents told me
about every day how lucky i was to be in
america and not how they grew up rubbing
your face in that [ __ ] son he would make
me feel like rubbing your face in a
pop-tart
[ __ ] 100
my mom told me when she came to this
country before she came her cousins told
her this is what they there was no
internet it was the 60s or whatever 50s
they said when you turn on the faucets
in america honey comes out because
that's what they thought america was
damn and that's where they were coming
to fully
[ __ ]
that was a fat joke and i couldn't get
it out
god damn it
they started flying in my head too quick
i was gonna i was gonna ask you what
neighborhood you're talking about
i think i know where i'm moving to
i remember i knew i was fat when i was a
kid we talk about the land of milk and
honey remember that yeah
and that would just make me so hungry
horny you mean
foley stop that
sorry teach no but i get uh and i see
like indians kind of talking about white
male privilege and this and that and i'm
like yo you sound so [ __ ] thankless
to me you sound like a spoiled brat you
sound like a kid in a two-story house
complaining about a kid in a gated
community
and it's like yo shut the [ __ ] up you
got a house you have a beautiful house
you have a beautiful family most likely
a beautiful culture so i'm mainly
talking to my people people that are
from where i'm from but i think a lot of
immigrant kids hopefully this will
resonate with them and then anybody
who's just a fan of me in general and
like comedy that's not supposed to be
on the quote unquote right side of what
you know it's a little edgy this guy's a
little bit yeah yeah
if we're not edgy we're not having fun
you know i know if i'm saying i've seen
a couple of people leave your show
mitchell
have i ever cared no one of them was
because of you what are you talking
about was that it was that oh yeah you
walked somebody on my show yeah you
insulted somebody surely or something
like that no
her husband was like the special teams
coach of the jets she's like do you know
who my husband is i'm like i don't know
nobody knows
they're the jets dog [ __ ] you're
threatening me with a kicker
a kicker yeah a kick i'm like what are
you gonna not let me walk on next season
get the [ __ ] out of here
good for you i love walking people
that's the best dude get out go it hurts
me i'm not a big fan of it but still ah
dude
please don't leave i'm sorry
no you're gonna get more as you get to
do this more i didn't get to headline
until like 2020. i was like 12 years in
so in a certain sense i had a lot of
growing to do but in a certain sense i
was pretty refined as a comic sure
and one way i was refined is like i
don't people are going to get up and get
that's fine that's going to happen but
as you get more confident in your
ability and as you start headlining more
and you strengthen that muscle people
leaving won't attack your insecurity as
much because it's like oh i'm funny so
you can leave if you want to not all of
you are gonna find me funny that's
that's fine yeah you're very okay with
that but
we are not okay with that at all i'm up
there tap dancing mommy love
dog
me
fall into the parking lot do a show just
for them
yo you want to talk about therapy
there's some therapy [ __ ] and this is so
hacky comic talk but it's a literal
thought i used to have in my head when
they would be calling me on stage
eastville was the only club i was passed
in for the longest and they'd be calling
me up on like a thursday friday night or
friday saturday night pack show i swear
the exact words that were coming into my
head as i was about to go on stage were
i hope these people don't realize i'm a
complete phony right oh yeah and then
they're talking about that today and
then the second they
your brain that voice starts going holy
[ __ ] they're finding out yeah and then
you start talking fast and cussing more
if you think they think they might as
well think yes yeah and your list most
people don't pick up on it but you will
listen back to that set and be like ugh
why'd i do that and i've learned i'm
legit this is so corny but before i go
on stage i will say something that
andrew used to say probably don't need
to anymore but i am good enough they
don't dictate whether or not i'm good
enough they could not like me that
doesn't mean i'm not good enough
they don't have that power so i just go
up there and then when they don't laugh
these guys are millionaires and not
awesome
dude we're in the back i'm like we both
suck why these people are here
toby get off stage
start
well i literally have to i i had to tie
his shoes at the gramercy theater like
three weeks ago i'm not even [ __ ]
around
that's what we were doing
they were new pants let me ask you all a
question i'm not even you two are doing
[ __ ] pep talks i'm literally tying
his shoes [ __ ] gary vee's over here
and you can bleep this out if you want
to i'ma ask you a question answer it how
much a month do y'all make on patreon
it's funny you bring that up uh it's uh
well you make twenty four thousand
dollars there you [ __ ] go you think
some bummers you told me five
god damn it you dump it dump it you
think some bum ass
do you think some bum ass not worth it
not good enough human beings are going
to make 24k a month on patreon yeah do
you think people are going to line up
over everybody's eyes no
[ __ ] that we're here talking about
pop-tarts what are you doing [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that's actually british which is
weird that's it
y'all got it a lot of people want to
come on flagrant too we put y'all on
it's true not not everybody got it
honestly you and not everybody has it
you all together really got it but
individually you got it too otherwise it
wouldn't work together so you got to
tell yourself that and a lot of your
friends are like that's stupid that's
y'all do that [ __ ] too [ __ ] everybody
and yourself whenever you're like nah
and [ __ ]
that has been the biggest thing that's
held me back in my entire life and as i
work on it everything changes it is so
corny i write myself the [ __ ] notes
i'm good enough before i go on stage i
will literally type out they could not
laugh that's okay it does happen to a
lot of it it happens
it is it will happen to me a lot of
girls prefer
my i bought my ass off at city winery
this summer and i was i was [ __ ] up
for a couple hours but then after now i
look back and it's so funny bombing in
retrospect is always so funny in
retrospect it's still it's you got the
heat on you when you walk off stage oh
that's natural you can't you can't not
feel it even if you're like mostly okay
it hurts but at the end of the day that
doesn't mean one bomb does not define me
once crush does not define me i'll say
the same thing i'll say whether this set
goes well or goes poorly it does not
change the fact that i'm good enough
nothing changes then so i go up there
and i as long as i have fun
everything else will be okay
there is no bombing if i had fun damn if
i have fun i d i get to you know what's
crazy about we gotta get you in like
college basketball locker rooms i know
fire up some of these kids i'm ready to
start doing drills right now buddy
that's what's crazy about stand-up is
you get to dictate how well it goes even
if they laugh or not if i had fun it's a
win we think it and i'm not saying i
adhere to this and i remember this in
the moment i forget all the time but i
remember off stage not often enough on
stage but i dictate how this goes if i
had fun no one can tell me it wasn't fun
damn and as that happens what the [ __ ]
happened to akash this guy's [ __ ]
crazy over here buddy i'm telling you
getting out on the road has helped me a
lot because i used to doubt myself all
the time and i remember andrea at a
legit pep talk with me on the podcast he
was like dawg you're one of the nicest
comics out there why do you not know
that it was like a 20 minute talk on the
pod like stop this [ __ ] and it was
because i never i'm sitting here doing
[ __ ] 15-minute club sets i'm 12
minutes in and you can't really grow
doing that sure but then as i got to get
out there and do 45 45 45 and breathe on
stage and [ __ ] get into the [ __ ] that
i want to get into i was i felt
confident and i was like oh i am
actually good at this and then you do
all that other work in the therapy and
all that [ __ ] and then when those two
merge
you're good you're good because you've
done the work y'all i see you at the
[ __ ] village lantern barking the
first you get into new york you guys
have done the work you put in the grind
you and i have talked about how we write
super similar sure our whole process
super similar so you're you just gotta
get to that point where you're like yo
i'm good whether they laugh or not
it doesn't mean i don't if i bombed i ha
i [ __ ] up and i need to work to fix it
sure at the end of the day it's my fault
but it doesn't mean i'm not good enough
as a comic it just means i bombed and
this night i [ __ ] up damn
this is this is the money talking right
yeah what's going on this guy's been
going to whole foods for the last six
months his brain's operating
that's not fair i don't go to whole
foods you guys got a river view you know
what i mean i don't go to whole foods
whole foods comes to me it gets
delivered on amazon
this guy's got amazon prime i'm not good
i'm not in line with those [ __ ]
mongrels okay
those homeless people yeah no but i this
is a thing and like as my confidence is
growing in my
uh
yeah yeah just say confidence and my
skills i think have caught up to where i
wanted them to be now i feel like this
is my time for the special like let's go
i'm proud of the jokes if you watch an
hour after this special comes out
different hour and it's i think it's
going to be maybe even better than what
i put out maybe if not
you will walk out of my show being like
yo that [ __ ] you could like me
or not like me but you'll say
objectively that guy is skilled at this
thing
the bald guy that opened for him
that bad host didn't do too well
the bald guy who talked about having a
small penis also wasn't so strong
i want you guys to come on to my show
and [ __ ] bomb your ass off at least
once i think i just bought earlier
i didn't notice i guess you weren't new
brunswick a few months ago
i guess you weren't at your show didn't
have the sound on in the green room
i told you we didn't tell you i bombed
when schultz did his first residency at
new york comedy club bombed on one of
those shows too i know scooter braun was
in the audience
but i did that same move i didn't know
if they had the sound on in the green
room if he knew so like when i went in
to like you know check with him i was
like hey kevin's on now uh you'll be up
in a couple minutes he's like okay and i
just i stood there for a second like
all right nothing everything
i saw him deliver his closer and a
tumbleweed blew across the stage
a posse rounded up they got him the
lights started
when they're just staring at you is the
funniest
like they truly want to laugh but they
don't know where they're supposed to
it's a tough one
my favorite bomb is like
they're not gonna do the math on it
they're like i don't even get this what
is this guy i like you
i just wish i liked your comedy oh no i
don't watch the simpsons what the [ __ ]
buddy you're killing me
oh my god dude buddy congratulations i'm
so happy for you thank you i'm excited
i'm the [ __ ] special bring back our
poo gang you gotta [ __ ] watch it yeah
it's gonna be [ __ ] absolutely
fantastic childhood hero uh let's get
into a couple of cues here yes sir as
you know we got family here we got a
little company here akash oh big cav
shout outs to big kev he's shot the
entire special edit it with me he edited
it i just told him what to do uh and
this guy is also my bodyguard so love
big he's up yeah shout out to big kevin
he's sitting on the couch right now he's
akash's t-bone yeah he's 6-11 he's huge
big-ass white boy i also did the thing
when i met him like hey you play
basketball can you dumb you know what
size shoes do you have i just asked him
to see his piece
yeah let me see your pizza let me know
if you can dunk or not
kippy three words you're gonna love
helix helix helix
you know what i'll say one more time
helix the greatest mattresses
in the world yes cause what happens you
gotta go to the mattress store you gotta
walk around you got some bozo with
coffee breath and a tie breathing down
your neck and a short sleeve shirt he
doesn't know what's going on no you go
to helix you take the quiz you know
exactly what kind of match that quiz
probably takes what 30 40 minutes two
minutes two minutes two minutes you're
in and out two minutes ain't the lsats
pen
we're sleeping here guys as you know the
uh the great helix company was nice
enough to give uh give us a give me a
mattress me and my lady took the sleep
quiz i took we ended up getting the
twilight series
um it was so good we had a queen i loved
it so much we upgraded to a king yeah
now we're living it baby uh and i got
the queen i got the queen come over and
use it sometime if you want still got
that kippy smell uh
yeah so if you're looking for a mattress
take the quiz you order the mattress
that's matched to you and the mattress
comes right to your door shift for free
you don't ever need to go to the
mattress store again nope uh helix is
awesome but don't take our word for it
voted best overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine that's top
notch publications there you go helix
has been recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep so here we go just
go to helixsleep.com
garbage take the two-minute quiz they'll
match you with the customized mattress
for the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders crazy and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com garbage
one more time that's helixsleep.com
garbage do it this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp yes gang the good people
who better help want to help is there
something in your life that's
interfering with your happiness as you
know uncle hanks the big man started a
therapy journey yeah a few months ago
i'm telling you it helps to talk it's
very important and if you live in
regions of the country whether you don't
have certain specialists better help is
even more important to you because you
can have access to specialized
counseling yes it's not a crisis line
it's not a self-help line it's
professional therapy done securely
online these are pros service available
worldwide you can log into your account
at any time send a message to your
therapist you'll get a timely and
thoughtful response plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone
sessions so that eliminates sitting in a
weird uncomfortable room you can hear
the guy in there before you crying or
screaming or you know punching a pillow
or whatever uh it removes all that
awkwardness uh special offer for ru
garbage listeners you get a 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage one more time that's
betterhelp.com garbage big kev shout out
shout out to big kev love that big
coverage gang as you know when you sign
up for the patreon there you get a
couple of questions asked on the air
mm-hmm we got some here that we're gonna
uh work out with mr outcast thing yes
have a good time uh speaking of patreon
nice we have to announce that this is
the public episode we talked about it
what do you think about this we talked
about it on our product we talked about
it on the patreon uh but you know we do
we lean we do the goals of course
the best followers we just hit 2 800
patrons so i'm taking big man to disney
for the first time world not land doing
the whole doing the whole [ __ ] ring
he's going to get stuck on a roller
coaster
doing the whole [ __ ] ringer toby's
going
down shoot everything yeah yeah yeah we
put it all on the patreon you get some
of the big turkey legs uh like we did
that we did like cribs of like our
childhood homes we did you know some
other we did are you on a harry potter
world or can you not fit on the rides
this is we we literally on the patreon
episode had to google uh disney world
for fat people to see what what and
there is like a dot org that like there
is a shocking amount of information on
that yeah there's a lot of fat
[ __ ] stay away from it's a
wonderful life
but universal studios at the hot dog
park unfortunately the universal studios
i assume less fat than disney i don't
know why but i feel that way yeah no
universal studios i think they'd be
fatter
why because they what do you have more
interest in
because that'll dictate what your
like-minded people do
i have interest in fatter to be honest
with you um
i don't want to go to harry potter all
respect i told you fat people don't care
for harry potter ah get out of here with
that everybody calling me hagrid and
[ __ ] i'm not [ __ ] doing it um i want
to go star wars
oh is that there star wars would be cool
yeah yeah that's disney again you're
disney i'm telling you fat people prefer
disney i don't have any empirical
evidence except you but i know this very
small i don't even want to go
[Laughter]
um there's a lot of there's a lot of
heavy set folks down here yeah there is
it's bill you know we're going to get
him a rascal for a day i mean it's not a
[ __ ] tough mudder race
who do you think is gonna be down there
cyclists what are you talking about a
bunch of dumbos walking around yeah
they're serving funnel cake and [ __ ]
huge lollipops
if you walk though you will lose weight
no rascal you just walk that whole
[ __ ] park every day you're gonna lose
weight in two days yeah dude you how
much weight you have to lose
i don't know if you hit ten thousand
steps i think you lose like forty pounds
because he does ten thousand a day i
think my deep fried oreo intake down
there is gonna happen scales on that
um but that was our last goal that we
just hit so our new goal
is um
we're going to spend it all baby yeah
we're gonna do a
ten thousand dollar roulette spin on
black i love that when we hit 3 400. one
spin once and then they're all on board
it's either going to make the rest of
the night [ __ ] awesome or it's going
to [ __ ] suck
the only concern my wife has to pay the
rent
either way it's going to be a good time
the only concern i have for you guys is
it's just the one spin how are you gonna
do content beyond the one spin we're
gonna have a dinner beforehand okay oh
we have a lifetime of foley's anxiety
that will
go into it he we came up with it the
other day he couldn't he's been he
couldn't sleep last night if y'all
listen if y'all go to 3 600 i'll put in
half with you i'll put in another 10k
3600 and then if then if you win we
split the profits wait what and if you
lose it is what it is
okay so we go to 3 600 patrons 3 600
patrons you'll you'll match the bet i'll
match the bet really yeah all right
that's it you're like
my hands are sweating
what about you big guy you want to get
in this action
i want you to flash that piece i've got
10 bucks on it right now trump's the
keys
i'm betting his salary ten thousand
dollars of his salary so you're in
regardless yeah i said it to toby's like
there's no way we're doing that man
started freaking out [ __ ] what's
what's it all about going in there and
[ __ ] laying it all in the water
that's the most new money thing is make
a bet that you for sure can't afford and
i'm already working on how i'm going to
fall into the table or [ __ ] fake a
heart attack
when this thing comes up on red yeah if
it hits throw a bunch of pigpon balls up
in the air [ __ ] run out the door
and if you win what are you gonna do
i think the goal is to blow it that
night yeah
okay all right i want my attention
they're gonna be the saddest like you
know
drinking at an irish pub or you know
when i find out you blew my 10ks well
after winning i'm going to be limited
fully what the [ __ ] before we get down
there hey sorry big man hit it hit red
akash
[Laughter]
oh yeah we're telling you we lost our
garbage alternate ending let's do it no
but i'll do it 36 though you gotta hit
36. all right 3600. damn this just
escalated quickly yeah how he came up
with it was our was the guy who helps
with editing new guy luke was like on
entourage they would walk in and they'd
bet ten thousand on red right off the
rip and we were like [ __ ] yeah we were
screaming we were drinking at a dinner
and we're like let's do it that's what
we're doing and then we ended up in
france we reviewed the clip and it turns
out they bet five bucks
but we were already dead set on the 10
000.
i already committed yeah and then i was
like well maybe five thousand what about
2500 you know what i mean
[ __ ] you luke 10k slapping it all down
yeah
oh man it makes me sweat thinking i like
gambling but 20k on black not when it's
more than i have in my bank account
all right or we could split 5k each week
no or
on one number how about this why hold on
i i have a proposition for you think
about that payout though how about this
180k we make the initial we make the
additional
initial 10 000 bet if that hits then you
come in and we double down all right
what would have to put up 20k
no i put in 10 y'all put your 20 then
it's 30k you win 60.
i'll take my 20. wait hold on you're 40.
everybody lit what's wrong with you guys
yo if we get schultzy involved in this
week
we could be buying a casino
if we go threesies oh dude i'm sorry i'm
talking
let's see what we can do if schultzy
wants to come in on top if that one wins
then we also met a [ __ ] with his money
to be honest i'd be teasing him all the
time safe ass bet
but yeah this is this is a man who is
very comfortable with the ups and downs
of bitcoin who's spitting off yeah yeah
yeah this guy's getting fleece today by
the way i checked the reports
i wish it would [ __ ] crash the 5k i'd
put so much in
yeah this you can't trust this guy
this guy's [ __ ] bonkers
he wants it to tank so he can buy more
that's a psychopath
jesus christ let's do it dude why are
you so nervous dude it hadn't even
happened yet that's a lot of money put
10 g's on i could easily back out
i could just be doing we get down there
hey sorry something's wrong with
i don't know what to tell you
what do you got td i'm sorry about that
we're running from the atlantic city mob
i'm getting escorted out of the borgata
oh you're doing vegas or ac
acc we're an atlantic city family yeah
[ __ ] vamping on a plane to lose
technology i'm not going out to one of
those rug joints yeah but you can't even
you can't even enjoy the [ __ ] dinner
in ac
they got a carrabbas
there's an outback yeah no they got the
car that car
oh god all right let's do it let's do
some [ __ ] questions here guys so when
you sign up for patreon we will answer
oh sorry real quick if we hit if we hit
the
10k in atlantic city we're going to come
to new york and eat the [ __ ] meal of
our lives not eating in atlantic city
we get something on the way
stop at farley's or something on a
parkway yeah i'm rich at that point i'm
not going hungry
okay get it i struggled my whole life
and i finally got money on me hungry
swing by roy rogers or something
uh yeah okay no there's good the more
guys i you know i've never i've
never really eaten them there but i
think there's nice places there's so you
can get a good steakhouse i thought we
were doing vegas buffets now y'all are
eating [ __ ] it you think i'm gonna
that's insane you think that's classy a
vegas buffet
it's better than atlantic city you know
the one time i walked to atlantic city
gordon ramsay's down there what are you
talking about they do i had a great
burger
those cheese steak egg rolls were
gourmet i don't think you understand how
garbage we actually yeah
yeah dude that's embarrassing but a
vegas buffet that's classy no i've never
been to the state myself i've been to
nevada but we went to it's pretty trashy
we went on a family vacation to san
francisco and our whole family when we
got there we drove down to reno for one
night to go to a buffet at the golden
corral
you know the golden nugget it's just
generational trash
this is [ __ ] eons of garbage
generational trash
generational garbage these are dirty
dirty people what does a vegas buffet
look like they got some nice buffets
down there really at the nice hotels
yeah i mean it's like a hundred bucks a
person but it's a good food crop
would they transfer
do they work together like can we there
is like i have appetizers at harrah's
and then go down to circus circus
are you asking if your buffet credits
transfer like community from atlantic
city to vegas
like if we win the money in ac could
they have a jet waiting for us and be
like yeah we're sending the boys out
there is like a buffet tour that's like
he hit four different buffets
i know of this
i don't know if it's still exciting for
the next goal yeah there you go four
thousand like this yeah four thousand
four buffets
you're gonna go to vegas
[Laughter]
go to vegas put 20 700 or 20 000 on red
there you go oh
that's um
okay but hold on go back to this maybe
if we
um if we do win the first bet
right i say we take
a thousand embedded on a number
okay that's pretty good because you're
playing with house money yeah all right
we take a thousand we bet on a number
and then and then we lose that double
down what do you mean i thought we're
not gonna leave my double down idea no i
think double down i think you pull you
pull the initial bet
oh yeah you take yeah i mean
this is coming from a guy who's never
gambled and he hasn't stopped talking
about gambling since this has come up i
just googled most expensive buffet
atlantic city and it's the one of the
borgata and it's 30 bucks
breakfast lunch and dinner we can bring
some friends
big kev what are you doing when we hit
3600 or if it goes south we're all split
in one plate that's like three bucks
each
yo that's going to be fire content we're
all going down there together big cav
will come yeah we got two camera people
now and we're gonna make it a [ __ ]
night well that's the thing i don't know
if you can shoot in a casino you
probably gotta go like [ __ ] real
covert ops we got to get body cameras
we'll get oh yeah i collect those hats
i'll wear a fake mustache yeah the pens
you put your [ __ ] phone on in your
pocket just have it peeking out there
you go we got it yeah got it guys we got
it then you take yeah if we listen
[Laughter]
that's the most expensive scooter no
scooter bro
you're sweating i don't give a [ __ ]
who's watching
that's [ __ ] crazy so if we win 20k we
put two on you you we'll take a thousand
for mars you take a thousand from yours
and we'll put it on two numbers put it
on two none of us hits we split that one
of us hits we split that
okay that's pretty good he's up look at
this
g's up we got it done all right damn oh
my god that's [ __ ] we're really in
this i wanted to announce
i just broke a lease on an apartment i
can't afford
[Laughter]
we are we are going to be oh [ __ ]
come march we're going to be upside down
i want to check out the middle class
famous tour ladies and gentlemen let's
start selling some tickets on the
[ __ ] road if we lose i won't have to
worry about getting fat that month
it might be the best be the best thing
for my overall health i still have i
have to tell my wife somehow
who paid for all this
who's not going to be happy i'm taking
the ten thousand dollars or we'll get
her original investment back yeah one of
the other uh my wife will never know so
there you go that's that's how i get
around it yikes why can't you have
confidence me yeah i have confidence
that we're gonna lose
[Laughter]
are you gonna tell your parents no way
what
i don't think anyone in my family's ever
all combined has ever gambled no ten
thousand dollars total my parents might
think my parents have ever gambled they
don't go to the casinos if they do she
says to the slot machines if you want to
stretch it out just for the free trial
for the smoke if you want to stretch out
the content we could also take a
thousand and put it on a parlay sports
bet
if we win yeah we win
uncut gems what are you doing
that [ __ ] i'm gonna get shot in a
jewelry store
the [ __ ] out of here i like garnett in
this one
[ __ ] 12 theme parlay see what happens
you know i don't mind that either are we
millionaires or are we going home
well we're going home on the trotters
never bet the chariots [ __ ] you man
those races are too long that's what it
is all right all right let's get into
some [ __ ] questions this is a barn
burner already baby um all right this
one's from jaden uh do you believe in
fortune cookies no
it's pretty trash if you do they had me
crippled for most of my life
i would save them in a pocket yeah no
what oh they scared the [ __ ] out of me i
didn't know what was going on
you weren't like what i mean well
they're always like good they're never
like you're going to die
i was scared that if i that's how many
fortune cookies foley
he got to this is a problem
hey stop eating fortune cookies get your
blood sugar checked
no i don't even like the cookies oh i
love them dude i love them i have a such
a sweet tooth i'm such a fat kid at
heart i don't think they're that sweet
they taste like cardboard to me sweet
cardboard i like sweet cardboard i've
had fortune cookies when i wasn't having
chinese food like if they were just like
in the drawer from like old chinese food
orders just have them as a snack
but you always have to read the fortune
that's the problem because i'm worried
about getting the bad juju
you can't do because you can't eat a
fortune cookie without reading the
fortune no you got i tell piano i think
there's a moment where it gets you a bit
if it's like oh but then you gotta
remember it's a [ __ ] cookie yeah with
any just a hundred computer generated
fortunes and who gives a [ __ ] yeah no i
can't do that
i'm not strong enough for that
i believe the fortune cookie gods will
get me if i don't
if i don't play by the rules
doing big guy i was up the first three
and i'm
i should have i should have walked away
[Laughter]
the one said get an endoscopy right away
what the [ __ ]
have your prostate checked immediately
they said never walk away from the table
door in a heater but
[ __ ] winter winter chicken dinner
let's let it ride
just with a coffee table like the
outside of enron just shredded
maybe
we pull the number off the back of a
fortune cookies don't they have lucky
numbers oh yeah yeah yeah maybe we do
that for the number bet
okay
but there's six numbers right they're
lotto numbers or five numbers
right we'll pick a number either way
let's get a little number in mind if
it's thirty six hundred pages maybe i
don't know about you guys but i got a
hundred oh that's pretty good and the
the odds i think are thirty six to one
the payouts thirty five thirty five to
one
so okay so we'll do 3 600 and then but
is there a number 36 or i think it only
goes up to 35.
i don't know if you guys are making me
hungry with all this chinese
let's get some [ __ ] sesame chicken in
here get our heads
right
[Laughter]
all right um let's see
uh can i ask you this on a side note
it's a podcast do you like the chips
that they put out at chinese restaurants
with the duck sauce and the mustard will
you eat those
you know i'm talking about the crispy
noodles oh yeah dabble but they never
really do it for me nobody does chips
and salsa better than chips and salsa
yes
exactly i'm going to tell you this whoa
hop they're [ __ ] all hops are bull
hob's good blow your mind
you're the only guy who talks about
drunk food like it's gourmet yeah
[Laughter]
you guys been a taco cabana in texas at
midnight
cheryl's on the grill you're in for a
treat
he's rolling burritos tonight i'm the
only guy to ever have a chalupa sober
for breakfast
shout out to the chalupa um
kaby let's talk about that box of
awesome from our good friends that
bespoke pose did you say bespoke post
yes i did love them love the box of
awesome they sent us one absolutely the
coolest stuff you could ever think of
it's winter now yeah so they got some
real cool stuff could be some outdoor
stuff could be some stuff for the home
bar could be some grooming stuff and
they team up with emerging brands and
small businesses so you're helping out
small businesses yes then they have
collections for every part of your life
baby whatever you're looking for like i
said we said a hundred times they sent
us something i mean i got a camp and
stuff pocket knives cool duffel bag i
take with me on the road when i'm jet
setting you know what it's cool guys
[ __ ] you want to be stuck
it's the stuff that you see some other
guy having a way to work and you're like
i need that guy's cool yeah damn i want
one of them yeah that's where you get it
uh it's free to sign up you can skip a
month or cancel at any time uh they
release new boxes and every month across
a ton of different categories whatever
you're looking for they got you covered
uh and here's the best thing each box
only costs 45 bucks but what's in it
over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
what are we doing here what are we doing
tebow cut this what are we doing
uh each box of awesome you're supporting
uh small brands like the big man said
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com enter
the code garbage at checkout that's box
of awesome.com promo code garbage for 20
off your first box do it do it let's
talk about butcher box baby butcher box
butcher box my absolute favorite and the
people that run that company are insane
because they're giving away free
hamburger
they're giving away free ground beef
over there
top quality big man's got a chubby going
right now dude it's nuts i can feel it i
still got a freezer full of i know
salmon chicken pork top quality stuff
it's unbelievable yes meal prepping is
difficult butcher box is making it easy
it's a subscription service that takes
the guesswork out of finding high
quality meat
uh they source their meat from partners
with the highest standards of quality
for so no more searching the grocery
store for 100 grass-fed free-range
organic chicken wild-caught salmon and
more i've done that with my wife where
you're like dragging from one place to
another like where's the organic where's
the whatever they take that all out
right to the door you know you know
they're on the up and up too why because
sometimes things aren't available
because they're not in season yeah or
whatever or they don't have a good
source of course that's how you know
they're playing straight yes exactly uh
no antibiotics no hormones each box
contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
depending on the box you choose that's
24 individual meals packed fresh [ __ ]
frozen for convenience it's a no-brainer
gang and this is your chance to never
have to shop for ground beef again this
is bonkers stop ted don't tell them that
that's right butchers they're not is
giving new members free ground beef for
life what you better like burgers baby
sign up at butcher box slash ayg and get
two pounds of ground beef for free in
every order for the life of your
membership one more time log onto
butcherbox.com ayg to claim this deal do
it
crazy back to the show all right uh
you recently got married this is from
joshua uh have you ever forgotten your
significant other's birthday ooh
no because mine is so like her it's
right there everything now her birthday
is everything to her so that's the one
day i can't forget wow i didn't get her
request you like a monster i didn't get
a christmas gift but i was like [ __ ]
not even christian why you care yeah
that was a thing i got her something
later but birthday if i ever forgot
birthday would be a [ __ ] problem you
do like a trip do you do a dinner i
don't know but i just gotta know it's a
significant day whatever it is i have to
treat it as a significant day that's it
whatever happens my girl loves nice
gifts and all that [ __ ] but the most
important thing is i understand how
important this day is to her which to me
is like
growing grow up yeah everybody's got one
what are we doing people really stretch
their bra women in general seem to
really value their not all but a lot
it's a weekend care about the week it's
my birthday men have the birthday
beating out of them at a certain point
like you still care about your birthday
you're 14 grow up [ __ ] yeah no yeah so
that's why for us for me i was single i
was 31 i was like who gives a [ __ ] about
a birthday i called her first birthday
together i caused a huge fight all my
fault and i was like i don't give a [ __ ]
about your birthday and now i look back
i'm like oh that was a problem special
day of the year
i [ __ ] up my bad
i always felt like a loser i always
wanted to be at other people's birthday
parties rather than mine
i don't know why i just didn't like it
we did we were was this on a public
episode or patreon where we talked about
the birthdays
paycheck what were you did you have any
birthday parties growing up yeah yeah my
parents didn't make a lot of money for
the wild but they did a good job taking
me to like putt-putt and my friends and
with how they probably spent hundreds of
dollars on [ __ ] arcades or whatever
any surprise parties no i never had a
surprise party oh my parents threw on my
mom and my now wife threw one what's
funny though is i've never i think it's
happened twice in both times i was like
i know there's a surprise party but i
have to pretend i don't know really how
do you feel about surprise parties in
general it's nice it's nice if you can
pull it off go that's great good for you
i've thrown one or two i think but like
that's sweet
thing what do you think
i don't want to know i don't know i
don't yeah i don't like not knowing
stuff me and my wife aren't big on
surprise she's like i got you something
like tell me what it is before it gets
what is that i don't like being [ __ ]
up
what what are you getting bamboozled
somebody does a generous thing for you i
don't know that's and you got to suck
all the fun out of it tell me what it is
[Laughter]
this guy's got my number
man i was thinking i'm like he's gonna
call me out on some [ __ ] horseshit
today i know it last time i was like dad
now it's my wife
uh oh no never i might want to cause
problems with you and your wife but it's
a surprise buddy who gives a [ __ ] i
ruined the surprise party one time
my ex
my girlfriend in high school i saw him
from three blocks away
[Laughter]
they heard him walking down the block
the water started shaking
he was wheezing
my my
[Laughter]
pretend like you're sleeping
my cannonball splash you can see it from
miles away
now [ __ ] i went outside to smoke her
parents hated me too it was [ __ ]
brutal it was the worst feeling she was
throwing you at surprise party no it was
her it was her 21st
birthday surprise down in her basement
you can [ __ ] up a cup of coffee
that's the rule you don't go out to
smoke and zig when you know she's in
route because you're getting a call or a
text she came down the wrong way too
because we went out like through like
the storm door like in like in like a
basement would have it was like a brand
new nice house and she was supposed to
come down like through the you know the
regular side but she saw me and [ __ ]
came over there on that side and we were
all facing the other way waiting for her
to come down
all of a sudden you hear what are you
guys doing
oh man to look her mom shot me yikes oh
my god that's so funny ruined it that's
like a sitcom moment ruined it
jesus what was the question again
um i forget where how the [ __ ] we got oh
by or forgetting your spouse's birthday
oh yeah we forgot toby's birthday we
just that's what we were talking about
we literally just forgot toby's birthday
yeah
i don't remember men's birthdays very
often i don't either i see it on
facebook i'll shoot you a text or
whatever yeah that [ __ ] is kind of yeah
also what i don't like
i get text or facebook messages from
people that are just happy birthday and
then i don't talk to you for a year then
your next text is happy birthday
birthday and i'm like what are we doing
here yeah yeah dinner and a cake dinner
and a cake that's it
any man who cares about his birthday
needs to grow up that [ __ ] is
embarrassing yeah you need to grow up
yeah yeah dude
as a guy who was just crying last week
in here that we forgot his birthday
[Laughter]
loan on his own cupcake
i'm sure they're just busy your family
and your wife should know and care and
that's it everybody else who gives a
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah what's yours
february 26th february 24th 1976.
it's coming i know because now i know
why i know and i book all the [ __ ]
flights that's how i know it
don't have to bleep that you can't have
your birthday out there right does
nothing get in you are you getting where
what are you thinking that's one of the
questions there's an entire website
called celebrity birthdays
am i on there
[Laughter]
somebody put them on
it's the wrong birthday
you know it's more embarrassing i was on
there and then they just stopped sending
me
last year nothing yo one year you got an
anniversary card
[Laughter]
they got a [ __ ] uh remembrance card
hey we heard you died
uh oh this is perfect speaking of this
is from uh mums to mums toe separators
don't get that um do you have a funeral
song picked out no we don't do that [ __ ]
indians don't do that you burn the body
you move keep them yeah they're not over
there playing journey like a bunch of
animals i mean you just set it up in the
village we burn the body and keep it
moving yeah come on bro damn you got a
song wait
i mean we cremate all the bodies the
couple funerals i went to i was crying
my ass off and then somebody was like
this isn't what we do we
celebrate your life and then we you know
we move on you have another life you
reincarnated you keep going have you
ever gone to reincarnated that sounds
pretty good
yeah it's not bad have you ever have you
ever been to a funeral in india where
they did like the old school cremation i
haven't been to a funeral in india but
there's like i thought they like put
they built like a pirate yeah and burn
you yeah they do yeah i have to do it
right there i haven't seen that but you
see that in movies it's like hibachi
over there over there roasting
marshmallows
uncle lenny has good flavor i'll tell
you that
uh i haven't seen it i don't know they
still do it i see it in movies and stuff
and then when i went to india after my
grandfather died the first time it was
like 10 days after he died or five days
or something so i'm you're still
mourning for 13 days but i didn't see
the actual funeral gotcha yeah
what's your funeral song uh
first of all this isn't your walkout
music you don't get a funeral song yeah
you do they're not gonna it's you're
special
yeah and what are you gonna are you
gonna introduce me what are you gonna
have like a little ladies and gentlemen
[Laughter]
my best pal where would that be played
are you gonna have that played in like
the church on like a little disc man at
the viewing or something i'm sure they
got a sound system i mean this is what
they do for a living they're now you're
not walking in with a walkthrough you
can't start cranking the mensingers in a
[ __ ] funeral no i won't uh uh mo
money mo problem
the edited version that is
my mom's gonna be there what are you
talking about
your story just reality my mom's still
there everyone's gonna everyone's gonna
pause and have your song
they've got a luncheon to get to [ __ ]
and now with the request of the deceased
hit him up
that's why i [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ]
i said edited
oh my god
do you want to be buried with anything
like you
[Laughter]
like sunglasses or a harmonica or
something
i don't even i don't know how to play
[ __ ] harmonica no what i um i do want
which they you know i want the old irish
week where you're you're i think we
might have talked about this where
you're like what they put you up yeah i
want to be like i want to be on like a
pool table at an irish pub and
everybody's just like surrounded by
flowers and everybody's just boozing
around yeah i know that's a good time
yeah it's nice
[Laughter]
that's a good time that's an irish wake
right yeah i think yeah why not go out
one last party open bar
shots don't get people i definitely want
to be cremated 100 percent i want to be
cremated and put in
my ears why would you do that climate
change already a problem
[ __ ] ozone's going to be gone that
puts it right over the edge ah there
goes miami
this fat [ __ ] energy cremated
but people have any family in downtown
los angeles cause they're all underwater
oh my god there goes miami
oh [ __ ]
that's a good time yeah cremate is the
way to go
um
all right this is from tj did you ever
own a bowflex yeah
really
really yeah
how'd you have money for that they were
my dad we had money for a bit for a few
years and then we lost it on [ __ ] like
bowflex
his mom's got the thigh master gun yeah
that's a guy that's a guy who's not
gonna have money for long when you buy a
bowflex yeah both legs yeah
that was be a gentleman get the total
that was walker texas ranger right no he
did the total gym that was like the i
think inclined with the thing right yeah
the bowflex is the power rods the
bowflex
i bid hook and sinker
yeah it's a stainless steel construction
that makes it worthwhile my dad was like
i did the math and it would cost
less to get a bowflex and get my whole
family a gym membership for like a year
so let's just do this and see how it
goes
and it never goes
my brother lost weight on it for a
little bit for me no my brother lost
weight on it for a little bit and then
my dad and mom didn't work out once ever
ever yeah never it was for like yuppies
in like the in the 80s i thought it was
just to look cool in the apartment while
you were yeah it was like the late 90s
that came out you remember the bowflex
toad yeah yeah yeah yeah so it did but
it didn't we definitely had a thigh
master i know that no we never did that
that was the only thing we steal over
here
we did that in a showtime rotisserie set
it and forget it
every sunday really yeah what are you
english royalty who makes cornish demons
do you guys hug them yourself seven
bucks for two we feed the whole family
i don't know if i could do that a
cornish gay man damn that's wild i don't
think i've ever talked to somebody who's
had one yeah it was good great
infomercials the flavor injector wasn't
[ __ ] though that blind really that blew
my mind the flavor injected it seems
like such a great idea yeah that blonde
lady was such a [ __ ] dingbat she
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
hey honey it's chicken relax will you
jesus christ oh my god did you ever put
anything besides like
anything that wasn't it wasn't made for
anything besides chicken
things but the chicken was just so
simple you just [ __ ] put that thing
on there and then let it go the rods
right what'd you put in there no i
didn't have one but like we had a
pizzazz we made a giant cookie on it you
know pizzazz are cool you know what
pizza that's just a pizzazz oh damn
pizzazz it's a pizza tray or something
yeah
p-i-z-i-z right smoking little doobies
that day huh
you and you're good what's a pizzazz
toby this it's like a heater so you can
put like anything on it frozen food or
whatever and then it like shoots heat
out of this thing it seems fire
cooks a pizza perfect yeah it's pretty
good air fryer changed my entire life i
can't get on i don't know what they are
buddy it's the [ __ ] greatest thing in
the world you just gotta get one really
i'll get a ronco before i'll get one of
those
if ronco starts making them i'm a
forming group think about it form and
grill nothing on the airfryer nothing on
the airplane what are you cooking in
there buddy somebody said you cook your
shoes anything yeah cook chicken wings
you might not even need any oil i'll put
like a tablespoon of oil chicken wing
seasoning 15-20 minutes that [ __ ] is
perfect it's like it's deep-fried it's
so good and that much oil bang whole
pack
what do you mean oil what are you
talking about oil where on the chicken
you know normally when they deep fry
things full this is a problem if you
don't know this this explains a lot to
be honest they drop it in a [ __ ] pool
of oil and that's how it fries
no i know but what do you mean you're
putting oil on it after the fact no but
when you before you cook it you season
the chicken you throw in like a
tablespoon of oil mix it up and then you
just drop that [ __ ] in the air fryer
maybe just like if you were putting
something in the oven yeah it's enough
it's just a small oven nah but it makes
things crispier than an oven it fries it
up nice
i don't get the frying thing but it's 25
bucks just get it
you'll get it you know what i mean just
get over my dead body giving them away
at bed baths that's the 2 900 patron
goals you guys get [ __ ] air fryers
i'm a pizzazz man through and through
yeah and i love the george foreman grill
wait air fryer i made french fries on
that [ __ ] i just cut up some potatoes
put that [ __ ] in there with some oil
toss it up put oil in it and then throw
it in there french fries done
i don't know everybody's pushing these
[ __ ] guys
and you leave it out on the counter the
whole time or do you put it away
we leave ours out
yeah it looks like something from star
wars i don't like yeah
looks like something to put like the cat
litter in
i mean there's no pizzazz but hey it
gets the job done i'm telling you give
it a shot we got water in here you'll
lose weight with one i think really if
you eat that over fast food yeah okay
yeah what if i do both but you put a
slice of pizza in there that's a day old
for 10 seconds or like 30 seconds
30 seconds 30 seconds man it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable what i
don't i still don't understand
chicken ring chicken wings from [ __ ]
raw in like 15-20 minutes you're not
talking frozen
i think like pre-cooked frozen wings
uncooked baby raw oh not frozen solid
it's got to be thawed but what have you
got a think tank involved in this this
guy did have a ronco rotisserie he might
know what he's talking about the ronco
was solid it wasn't the waste of money
that i thought it might be but it was
solid this [ __ ] is so worth it it's so
much better it's the best
kev you got one
it's fantastic right
thank you dog you gonna trust big cat if
you want to trust me what you got trust
big kev
shooter this guy i'm not keen on but
that's hey i get hyped up and buy into
things big kev is more stoic than that
he's more level-headed than me yeah
let's take a look at these air fryers
might be something to this could be a
little money in it though
get an endorsement deal h foley's air
fryers
i i had one for a little bit and i
called bobby kelly to ask him what i
should do with it he's like oh dude you
can do anything you do wings and my
favorite sausage and peppers
did you get one yeah you use it i i i
currently don't own anything okay the
bed bugs took it
they ate everything
[Laughter]
works great on bed bugs you lost it in
the bed bugs no i lost in the first
apartment purge but yeah no no more ah
we'll cut this out and keep moving
toby's hanging on by a real
threat i don't know if you're wearing
that i don't think these cameras are on
[Laughter]
literally i was like he's gonna be
walking out here with a box of his stuff
uh i would have made you buy me an air
fryer
damn
all right let's do a couple more here um
it's from tommy have you ever faked it a
pot have you ever faked a positive
coveted test
no no i'd definitely throw it out but
i've helped people fake positive
comments i've sent them my positive
covert test so they can fake [ __ ] whoa
that's a good friend it's a great
[ __ ] excuse of course i've been using
it i've used nobody wants to go near you
i've been expo i just found out i got
exposed yeah
i just got a text and he got it
i got i got to shut down the operations
over here oh yeah great great get out of
jail free card
nobody wants to go near you and i've
spread covert to many people so that you
know they're like yeah you've got a lot
of people
took out us yeah i almost ruined your
podcast
was that prevax too prevex it was yeah
you got sick prevax i got sick three
bags got vacs and i got sick post bags i
got omicron
omnicron so when yani rolled in here
that was all pretty bad he was on his
way when he was all giannis was on his
way here no i would have had to been
vaccinated no it was december there was
no i mean the backs had just come out
but like frontline workers got it no i
got it thanksgiving that could have
taken me out yeah yeah no air fryer in
hell
you don't need it you're the one there
um
yeah that was a go-to for a while then i
got it i was like is that karma is that
me throwing out bad karma
listen last night this kid hit me up
[ __ ] i hate this guy i didn't want to
go yeah i didn't want to go i wasn't
really near him but you know because i
can't stand the guy you know it's it's
crazy but just to be safe yeah i'm sorry
you're free [ __ ] out couple of eddies
throw on [ __ ] the book of boba fett
good night
it took a bubba man
oh my god um
all right let's see here
this is
this is from the savage cabbage do your
families have any garbage remedies or
cure-alls that actually work
you guys uh indians always use indian
stuff so like turmeric like haldi is
what we call it yeah my mom will use
that like she used to heat that up make
it like a paste with water heat it up
and then if i had a sprain or any
swelling she would just wrap my entire
appendage in it or whatever i sprained
my ankle my whole ankle would be wrapped
in it's stained yellow and turmeric yeah
turmeric with um maybe
onion or something but turmeric paste
from a couple chicks get some chicken
air fryer you got a [ __ ] party
and i swear to god that [ __ ] works so
well yeah yeah that's crazy but you're
like you have to wrap my foot in like a
[ __ ] plastic bag so i can stain
everything i touched
and you leave it and then the next day
i'd always be fine it increases blood
flow i believe is what it does probably
yeah turmeric is great for you my dad
ties it in a shake every day i recommend
that he have it in his uh his little
shake a little turmeric really good
turmeric and ginger it's really good
stuff ginger's good stuff yeah
um all right let's see this from tony p
ever pull a fire alarm for a reason for
any reason other than a fire i never
pulled a fire alarm in my life too
scared yeah i think even if there was a
fire i'd be nervous to do it
yeah it's not gonna get back on me
my fingerprints are gonna be in it no
that's a that's a trash move
have you ever been somewhere where
someone pulled it like a movie theater
or some [ __ ] yeah
i think in school it would have you know
it would happen from time to time
that [ __ ] didn't squirt out at you
though that was [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh they used to say there was like
mercury or something in the glass right
mercury
something like that they're not russian
agents what the [ __ ] mercury it was like
a blue dot or something
i don't know about what do you think
scorch botulism in your face if you pull
it
mercury what the [ __ ] man
isn't what's in the glass
yeah your school is [ __ ] up it was the
1920s did i tell you that
don't pull the fire alarm to get beer
sprayed
i don't teach you mercury
well isn't it in the glass like the
thermometer
i'm not wrong
it doesn't squirt it out at you
i'm asking what you meant you said it
squirts out i said oh what the mercury
yeah you they never told you that that
like if you pull a fire alarm it squirts
something on you so they know it was you
it's like a die pack no what that's
insane yeah they didn't they didn't tell
you that what you're in the middle of a
fire then all of a sudden you're a
victim of assault that's insane it's not
a lot it's so people wouldn't so so
people that pull fake fire alarms they
know what kid does that's something they
tell you so yeah
that's like the pain in the pool that's
that thing exactly yeah it doesn't exist
i didn't tell you that no no not at all
you hear that no i farted and it smells
that's my bed i'd even smell it yeah you
will is that tumeric
[Laughter]
a little bit somebody got a sprained
ankle what's going on
um all right let's see let's do one more
here
um
this is from tjb first time question
have you ever eaten at a grocery store
hot bar
yes [ __ ] [ __ ] yes [ __ ] love it yeah
bruh that's great especially if you're
doing like low carbs or something just
go get a bunch of meat and couple of
veggies out the door for like sesame
chicken mac and cheese mashed potatoes
and meatballs see you're laying off the
carbs
not now you know the the the stuffing
the choice bacon pandemic
yeah i was big especially especially in
new york when you're running around
spots and like if you have a day job
[ __ ] unbelievable i was the king of
hot bars i'll eat every deli i know had
they're gone now whole foods they're
back in whole foods now i think uh
cotton bar a little overpriced yeah it's
too much you had to go the you have to
go to like uh like a nice bodega in the
city especially around midtown that
keeps it clean like the working crowd
around lunchtime god damn the [ __ ]
plantains the salad the whole nine yards
i don't know who makes that chocolate
pudding
you're getting the chocolate pudding in
a hot bar that's crazy i did see one
time a homeless guy walked in and
grabbed just meatballs with his hand
right never again yeah why did i never
think that would happen that's insane
that i thought crazy people didn't walk
in and just grab food
yeah so you only got to go stuff they
can't grab with their hands [ __ ] the
spinach artichoke you know what i mean
man i love a [ __ ] hot bar dude
the only place you have like it's like a
buffet you know turkey meatballs [ __ ]
whole nine yards i once spent 30 on
supermarket sushi was a great day damn
supermarket sushi is all right but a lot
of times i got the guy back there
chopping up rolling it that's when you
know you got a real nice grocery store
when you got the guy back there you
don't have a guy
at uh now
uh maybe they do at mccaffrey's at the
wawa in south six and they don't have a
guy
give me a tuna classic and a spider
roller
what's the sake situation in here
gang mr akash singh brand new special
out right [ __ ] now you gotta check it
out bring back up who he's on tour right
now i believe yes sir yes sir he's a
killer go check him out let the folks
know what he got cooking what do you
want
to date let me plug the dates
okay
i'm doing a socal run february 20th i'm
gonna be in oxnard california at levity
live february 23rd i'm gonna be at the
improv irvine february 24th our ontario
improv and february 25th on being la
hollywood the dynasty typewriter theater
march 11th i'm gonna do a couple canada
days real quick march 11th vancouver
playhouse and april 22nd 23rd toronto
royal theater the rest of my dates are
on akashing.com
a-k-a-s-h-s-i-n-g-h dot com look at that
buddy it's a killer we love you we're so
proud of you happy thank you happy four
years [ __ ] absolutely fantastic thank
you for everything obviously always
kippy what do you got for him uh check
out our dates the middle class famous
tour hartford albany syracuse atlanta
tampa orlando pittsburgh buffalo detroit
denver phoenix salt lake city chicago
rosemont more dates coming check it out
come see us gang it's a fun time it's a
great way to introduce new people to the
show so bring this squad with you yeah
that's a great point people got to see
you guys in person to get well i mean i
see you guys in person but that's the
best way to get yeah it's a selling
point for sure the best way to get it
and check out the special and we love
you and we'll see you next week peace
god bless oh hater